un mois de juillet marqué par
l'installation des maires élus au second
tour joséphine coleman ce berger reste à
la tête de plaisir alexandra rosetti de
voisins-le-bretonneux la verrière trappe
les clayes-sous-bois villepreux sont
dirigés par de nouveaux et il
jean michel fourgous et réélu président
de saint quentin en yvelines un état
d'esprit j'irai de rassemblement de tout
de tous les élus on sent quand même 1 1
même une évolution et toute une histoire
cette agglomération qui monte en
puissance
une trappistes au gouvernement le 6
juillet nadia et se voit offrir le poste
de ministre délégué à la ville connexion
sera orientée particulièrement sur les
quartiers politique de la ville mais
tous les territoires fragiles et surtout
surtout je le disais tout à l'heure
cette réconciliation entre le rural et
la ville une nomination qui la pousse à
démissionner comme député de la 11e
circonscription un nouveau scrutin sera
organisé en septembre 40 millions de
masques pour les personnes précaires
cinq centres du groupe la poste était en
charge de la logistique
il ne doit pas il ne saurait y avoir le
moindre obstacle financier pour que les
français puissent se protéger elles les
vacances ont été apprenants pour plus de
25000 jeunes dont la moitié en éducation
prioritaire et on les a doublées
grâce au volontariat des chefs
d'établissement grâce au volontariat des
enseignants qui ont pensé qu' il était
souhaitable pour leurs élèves de pouvoir
proposer un programme de renforcement
clap de fin pour le summer camp dix
jours de découverte aux métiers du
numérique à saint quentin en yvelines
pour une cinquantaine de jeunes
depuis le 15 août les yvelinois doivent
se masquer le préfet du département l'a
rendue obligatoire dans les marchés
brocantes et vide-greniers
trente neuf mille mètres carrés une
quarantaine de boutiques restaurants
après trois ans de travaux le centre
commercial mon grand plaisir a ouvert
ses portes au public le 27 août
nous avons créé 800 emplois dont 600
emplois nets nouveau c'est aussi un
bilan positif pour l'emploi
une rentrée masqué pour les élèves comme
les adultes une protection apportée dès
l'âge de 11 ans les collectivités en ont
distribué les entreprises se sont
adaptées
on affaires principalement à des clients
qui bat qui ont également mis en place
ces mêmes c'est un objet c'est donc on
respecte bien entendu alors ça c'est
impressionnant de temps en temps c'est
qu'on a des grandes salles de réunions
pour 400 personnes un dépistage de
grande ampleur à saint quentin en
yvelines le vélodrome nationale s'est
transformé trois jours pour dépister les
salariés du territoire on a commencé
cette idée dès le mois de mars on l'a
proposé à rs mais à ce moment là les
tests n'étaient pas disponibles donc
aujourd'hui le sont elles les habitudes
des amoureux de la petite reine ont été
bouleversés la dernière étape du tour de
france est bien partie des yvelines mais
en septembre et les coureurs étaient
masqués le public éloigné une nouvelle
étape majeure dans la construction du
centre aqualudique de maurepas elancourt
le 21 septembre dernier le permis de
construire était signé
l'ouverture au public est prévue pour
2022 un retour au duel droite gauche le
second tour de la législative partielle
de la 11e circonscription a vu gagner le
candidat les républicains grande émotion
grande fierté d'abord pour le l'ampleur
du résultat
malgré une faible participation philippe
benassaya qui démissionne de son poste
de maire de bois d'arcy quelques jours
plus tard